One easy transformation we
can do is a circular review.
We'll cover other elements
of meaningful motion
in more detail later in the course,
so let's consider this a preview.
In this app, clicking one of
the recycler view items will kick off
a circular review transition
to new item texts.
The circular reveal effect is
used a lot in material design and
ties in nicely with ripples.
So let's talk a little bit
about how we're going to
make this circular reveal.
This is the signature of
the createCircularReveal function.
The view we're going to operate on,
a center X and
Y to start the transition,
a startRadius, and an endRadius.
So let's say this is the view group
holding the text we want to change.
First we need to find
the center point of our reveal.
We can do that by taking the item's
width and height and dividing in half.
The reveal should start from nothing,
so our starting radius is zero.
You might remember from geometry class
that the diameter is a line segment that
passes through the center and
whose end points lie on the circle.
The radius is half of the diameter.
So if we fit our item to a circle, and
situate the center points here to line
up, our ending radius would be
from about here to here, or
a little bit more than half
the width of the item.
One reason why it would
be a little bit more,
is just because if it's a square item,
it's not going to
perfectly align with a circle, so
you would need to adjust that.
So now we have all the pieces we
need to create a circular reveal.
As I mentioned before, you couldn't
just use half of the width of the item.
You actually need to use the hypotenuse
of half the width and half the height.
And here are all the components
of the createCircularReveal
function that create our animator.
After that set,
we chang the text, and the title,
along with the background color.
Lastly, we start the animation